شهرتها. يا لهذا الجنون. عند
الانتصار قد يكرم الغرب او بوتين
عن دورها كوسيط لايجاد حل مناسب
لانهاء هذه الحرب. فهل سيستطيع
العراقية بهذا السؤال. اليس
لديكم سيادة تحافظون عليها?
الولايات المتحدة تخلت عن سياسة
الحياد والتوازن في قضيتي قبرص
نصدره. فهل تنجح نظرية التنين
الصيني في اخضاع تايوان? تركيا
نفسها. بينما الصين بدورها
استيائها من التصريحات
كوريا الجنوبية. للخوف لغة لا
يفهمها الا السياسيون بينما
باليستية وضربات مدفعية وطيران
مسير. والنتيجة مقتل ثمانية عشر
قوته ولا تحلو المشاكل الدولية
والحروب الاهلية دون ان تكون
كبار السن والنساء يهرعون من
بيوتهم للنجاة بارواحهم. صواريخ
الحكومة الايرانية ان تتوقف عن
الدم العراقي لنتوجه الى الحكومة
المدمرات البحرية والغواصات
النووية. الاستفزازات لم تنتهي
بحسب استفتائها فمن يستطيع
اخراجها اليوم وها هو بوتين يوقع
امريكا هي المخرج الذي يعد هذه
المشاهد. هنا كاميليا نائبة
المتصاعد بين الام الصينية
وفتاتها الشقية تايوان في اوج
ثالث تزامنا مع اختتام نائبة
الرئيس الامريكي هريس زيارة الى
يتحدث بايدن لقد اكل بوتين
الكعكة كلها لوحده. وهل يستطيع
نووي واذا قال شيئا فعله. لينضم
اليها الرئيس التركي اردوجان
متابعين على يوتيوب تقتل زوجها
لانها اعتبرته عائقا امام
يعلنها مواطنو خرسون وزبروتشا
والدونيتس واللوجانسك اصبحوا
قالت ان الولايات المتحدة لديها
علاقات قوية مع كوريا الشمالية
والهدف منها حماية القبارصة
الاتراك حسب تصريحه ليدخل على
احد ان يثني الدب الروسي عن
قراره رده ياتي ممن كانت اقوى
المقومات الاقتصادية. وكما
يقولها اخواننا المصريون. الحلو
يختلطان فهذا حال اردوجان اليوم.
بدورنا تركنا مشاهدة المسلسلات
تواجه حرب طاقة مع روسيا ويتعهد
برد قوي. امريكية كانت تحلم بجمع
وهو تحالف متين وقوي. لنشاهد
الفيديو.
كمال الصبر حدود ايضا. بوتين صمت
لايام واصم اذنيه امام تهديدات
تعلن البيضة والحجر هي لعبة حفيد
ارطغرل المفضلة. وبنفس اللعبة
رئيسا على حد تعبيره ليجيب
الامين العام لحلف الناتو نؤكد
الاكسجين. هنا نخنق الضحية ليكون
للفريسة حلم لا يتعدى سقفه.
العراقي. لقد ارهقتهم الحروب.
فعن اي حروب نتحدث يا هذا تقصد
النوردسترين وتخشى الاسوء. وزير
الخارجية الالماني يقول ان بلاده
الجندي هي لغته المفضلة. فقد ودع
كوريا الشمالية باطلاق صاروخ
جندي تركي في قبرص الشمالية
ليؤكد في اعلانه انه سيضاعف
كوريا الجنوبية ضمن جولة اسيوية
شملت اليابان. فبماذا سترد
الزعيم كم وليس المجنون ليكون
هذا هو حالنا الرئيس الامريكي اذ
العدد من حيث القوة والسلاح
بمختلف انواع خطوة جريئة وحازمة
للجنون فنون. بينما انت تؤدي
خطابك التاريخي للتفاخر بقوة
ولن تفرط بسيادة ومن وسط النزاع
العسكري الى الوساطة الروسية.
اوكرانية. اصل الالمانية تمنع
التوقف والتصوير في محيط خط
واعلان روسيا الاستفتاء. ورغم
تعقد الموقف فان انقرة لم تتخلى
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوجان
ان بلاده وجودها العسكري في
لا يلتفت الى ذلك ويستمر
باحتفاله بنصر علمه وانكار
مستعدون تماما للدفاع. يجب ان
اكرر هذا. امريكا مستعدة تماما
اوكرانيا كحقل تجارب. اتهام خطير
يضع الغرب في شبكة الشبهات. فمن
كوريا. نعم. فقد اخطأت بنطقها.
وقالت كوريا الشمالية عوضا عن
وعظمة دولتك هنا تسمع صوت صاروخ
باليسي والمصدر هو هذا. نعم
الحروب السياسية ام حروب انتهاك
السيادة؟ هناك طفل يختبئ وهنا
التركية لنلتفت الى مسلسل تركيا
واليونان وكانت اخر حلقاته اعلان
الحصول على قليل من الاختناق
الاقتصادي لتايوان. هذا ما
وبحر ايجا لصالح اليونان. واكد
ان تركيا لن تقف مكتوفة الايدي
اعذارها وتقديم اي تفسير تجاه
هذه الخطوة. فهناك اربعون الف
نفس الخط وزير الخارجية التركي
مولود شاوش اوغلو ويصرح قائلا
في اوروبا والقوة هي من ستحدد
المستقبل في سياسة العالم. ويضيف
حفيد عثمان اطفاء هذه الحرب?
العراق يتألم. هيا لمواجهة
سؤالنا للمحيط. ما الذي اقلق
هدوءك ليأتي الجواب من اصوات هذه
يدعون للتظاهر. نعم. العراق
يمتلك الثروات والكثير من
تستخدمه الصين حاليا. فالصين
الان لا تستقبل اي بضاعة تجارية
من تايوان وترغم حلفها على ذات
النهج ليبدأ النواح من سكان
قيودها وتقديمها السلاح لنيقوسيا
ليؤكد ان امريكا تتخبط في
والحرب الكلامية منها رائحة
البارود. لا يزال التوتر
مكالمة هاتفية بين بوتين
واردوغان في ظل تعقد الامور
شمالي جزيرة قبرص. وذلك بعد ان
رفعت الولايات المتحدة الامريكية
ايمن رايسين
بطائرات التمساح كاثنان وخمسون
الهجومية على مواقع عسكرية
وكيف تحولت ملامح المذيع عند
ظهور بوتين مخترقا القناة.
واشنطن تجاه هذا الفعل برأيكم?
الاحداث والتطورات. قصف روسي
امرأة في اوروبا المستشارة
الالمانية. بوتين لا يمزح بشأن
بلاده لن تعترف بسيادة روسيا على
المناطق الاوكرانية عن اي اعتراف
تايوان المدخول لم يعد يكفي ولم
نعد نجني سوى خمسين بالمئة مما
الرئيس الامريكي. واشنطن ستستمر
في دعم تايوان في الدفاع عن
الحروب اخضاع العدو دون قتال.
لتبدأ الصين باستخدام نظرية نقص
اسمعت الغربيين وليس اوكرانيا
فقط يا بوتين ولكن بطريقتك
صوتنا مسموعا على مدى الف كيلو
مترات. النصر لنا النصر لنا. لقد
مدنيا بينهم نساء واطفال. ومن
منبر قناتنا المتواضعة نناشد
ما يكملش. نعم هناك قيادات
سياسية فاسدة تنخر عظام المواطن
الفاسدين. لقد ضقنا ذرعا هيا
لنغير واقعنا. متظاهرو تشرين
استطاع ان يندمج مع الغرب ومع
سياستهم. رغم ان الزيت والماء لا
هكذا يقولها الروس. موسكو ادخلت
تلك المناطق الاوكرانية رسميا
مواطنين روس والى الابد. نعم لقد
فعلها الرئيس فماذا انتم فاعلون؟
على مراسم انضمام هذه المناطق.
ليخرج الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن
بوتين ينتهي اليوم. الصمت سلاح
مرعب لكن ليس دائما فللصمت حدود
الخسارة. نعم. هكذا قالها بوتين.
من الساحة الحمراء وحتى يكون
اليوم. ويا له من تفاوض. انه
تفاوض ما بعد الانتصار لا ما بعد
الامريكية. حيث قالت ان واشنطن
تقمع دولا اخرى دون ان تدفع ثمن
الناتو على غرار السويد وفنلندا
مشيرا الى ثقته بقبول جميع
ذلك. اذا فما هو الثمن يا اصحاب
العيون الضيقة. اهلا. فمن فنون
محذرا بشأن تهديدات الرئيس
الروسي ويؤكدانها معا. نعم بوتين
لا يمزح. خطة صينية خبيثة. امواج
البحر الهادئ لم تعد هادئة لنوجه
والمكابرة. في كييف وقع الرئيس
على طلب انضمام سريع الى حلف
جنبا الى جنب مع حلفائنا في
الناتو للدفاع عن كل شبر من
ويقول ان تلك الاستفتاءات صورية
ونتائجها مفبركة ومزورة، وان
الغرب حتى جاء اليوم الموعود
وبتصفيق حار من الحاضرين. بوتين
اراضي الناتو كل شبر سيد بوتين
لا تفهمني خطأ. كل شبر. فهل نحن
يرد ذلك الاتهام? وهنا الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن يقول نحن
على دعمنا لوحدة اراضي اوكرانيا.
لكن ماذا عن طلب زيلنسكي? صمت
الاعضاء وشدد على رفض بلاده
الحوار مع موسكو ما دام بوتين
في الحروب. لن افاوضك على ما في
يدي بل ساخذ ما في يدك ولتفاوضني
بوتين قائلا الغرب ينتج اسلحة
بيولوجية ويستخدم البشر في
المفضلة اذ اخترق جيش بوتين
الخفي وهم الهاكرز قناة دوتش
على اعتاب الحرب يا ترى? ومن قوة
الانتصارات الى رفض الهزيمة
تدفي اوروبيين خلال الشتاء
المقبل في اشارة الى ازمة الطاقة
بوتين القادة الاوروبيين ببث ما
وصفه بالدعاية الكاذبة المعادية
انتصار نتح وهكذا تخضع الصين
اعدائها وتايوان تستنجد. لقد
لروسيا وتوجه بوتين الى القادة
الغربيين بالقول ان الاكاذيب لن
نتحدث يا سادة ومن نشوة الانتصار
الى توجيه اصابع الاتهام. اتهم
العسكرية فورا وان تعود الى
طاولة المفاوضات. عن اي قوة
خطاب امين عام الناتو فجأة ويظهر
بدلا عنه بوتين يلقي خطابا على
هنا بوتين بكل تواضع يقول على
اوكرانيا ان توقف العمليات
القناة الالمانية. دعونا نشاهد
الرعب الذي تسبب به الاختراق
فيلا اثناء بث كلمة للامين العام
لحلف النيتو يمس تولتنبرغ. هنا
واوروبا يرد. في اوكرانيا يسمع
صدى اهازيج الانتصار لكن عن اي
متباهيا بينما يوقع طلب انضمام
لحلف الناتو والناتو ومجلس الامن
ya
عليه. نعم هكذا قاتل بوتين
ليأخذ. ثم ها هو يقبل بالتفاوض
المواجهة امام الدب الروسي.
سياسة الانتصار. هذه سياسة بوتين
انتهى وقت التفاوض. هكذا صرح
اردوجان ليبدأ بعدها اول تحرك
المجنون يتسبب بموقف محرج لنائبة
الرئيس الامريكي والمانيا. تعلن
امام ايران. ها هي طهران ترد
عسكريا لا دبلوماسيا. بينما
عسكري تركي. بعد ان قدم السفير
العراقي اعتراضا شديد اللهجة
Waktu والجلوس على الطاولة
للحوار مرغما. وهكذا قالها بوتين
Dua
اعدائه. فهل نرى ردة فعل غير
متوقعة من الغرب يا ترى?